today's guest is a writer he's a
stand-up comedian uh he has countless
specials um on Netflix uh he has his own
podcast called the jezel Nick Rosenthal
Vanity project that comes out every week
his latest special is fire in the
Maternity
Ward um he he's a one of one you hear
that term a lot but there's I've never
met nobody like this man and uh I've
always looked up to him and admired him
uh I'm really thankful to have him here
today on the podcast this is one of our
first times uh sitting down and talking
so today's guest is Mr Anthony
[Music]
jman I'll sit and tell you my
stories
sh on
me and I will find a song
[Applause]
I used to do this joke I was like you
heard what happened to The Fawns he got
AIDS and had that
to I did and I'd be like no we didn't no
we didn't guys after I had this joke
that I loved that was um my family was
exactly like the Brady Bunch we might
not have been perfect but my father did
die from AIDS and it kill in the
beginning the first 10 years of my
career it would kill so hard people
would be like I love that joke so much
and then all of a sudden it just stopped
working and I was like oh my audience
has gotten younger and they don't know
about the Brady Bunch they don't know
the guy the actor so I was like I got to
stop doing it yeah because I I think my
fear would have been that something oh
people don't love AIDS or they're not
they're they've everybody's gotten on
the side of like against AIDS you know
Theo people love AIDS it's like it's
like what what other disease gets it own
quilt yeah oh that's a great Point uh
yeah yeah you don't see like a
asthma Afghan yeah there nothing else
has that hype Anthony jelnick man nice
to see you dude good to see you man it's
been a while yeah it has been a while
yeah I mean I would see you like at the
store every now and again like we were
doing the store but now everyone's on
the road doing stuff as your friends get
successful and get busy you just never
see them again yeah is that I mean
that's probably happened cuz you've had
a lot of success for a long time sure so
did that happened like kind of I guess
you just noticed that like yeah it was
was it more fun before was it did it
start to get more like Lonesome like
what do you think it gets lonely for
sure because you come up with a certain
group you know and you think everyone's
going to make it there's like 10 guys
that you're with and you're like we're
all going to be Stars one day and then
like half of them quit you know the
other half are just like become writers
or something and then you're like oh now
I'm on the road I don't see anybody
anymore and you get a different group of
friends and they start doing movies and
[__] so it's like well I love this guy
but we never see each other cuz I'm on
the road and he's doing movies so you
just lose all your friends always yeah
and it's hard to have when you're
touring it's hard to even keep up
friendships it's like sometimes I get so
exhaust like I hate to say exhausted but
yeah I get exhausted with like
whatever's going on or responsibilities
and then if a even if a friend texts me
sometimes sometimes I'm like I don't
have I'm just not dropped into a space
where I want to engage in a conversation
yeah or you're like you're on the other
side of the country I'm not going to
write back right now well like you ever
like you get in a relationship and
you're you're dating someone for like a
year and you don't see your friends as
much and then you break up and you have
to like remind your friends that you're
still a person you know they're like oh
I know we haven't been hanging out but
you got to start calling me again oh
yeah you know like you were on the road
for a year and you don't hear from your
friends for three years cuz you'll see
someone and they're like what are you
doing you're like I'm I've been done
I've been around like why Haven we why
hav you called me you know you just you
don't see people and they're just out of
mind yeah I think it the the road makes
me feel like a bad friend a lot I think
because I'll come back into society like
reenter Society or something like a
PR like a convict or something you know
you kind of go through like a re-entry
where you see what you have in your
closet you're like holy [__] this
stuff's been out of style for oh yeah
and all your stories are about like a
driver you had that you didn't like and
I like we don't this is not a real life
we don't know we don't know what you're
talking about you had a bad flight okay
I'd love to fly somewhere yeah I'd love
to go anywhere yeah um yeah it's
interesting man it's interesting as it
get as your career goes on like what
it's like I think what I thought it
would be like maybe I I know I think
sometimes I think I stayed in comedy
because it I think I wanted something
that you didn't have any commitments
like in the world like I always got to
leave whatever relationship whatever
moment a girl was like what's going on
you know be like I have to be in you
know
Indiana so we'll find out when I get
back and then eventually come back
enough and and there that wasn't even
there anymore yeah I think a lifestyle
is a big draw to Comedy almost too big
big a draw you know you see the people
who get into it for the lifestyle and
then you watch them just destroy
themselves immediately the lifestyle is
attractive you know people like the
lifestyle more than the work nobody gets
to be nobody becomes a comic because
they want to sit and write jokes all day
they become a comic because they want
the Applause you know they want they
want to walk offstage and be like
where's the party yeah that's true right
because yeah people don't realize it's
just a bar it's like really just a bar
it's a bar business with like a dancing
guy yeah if you're like I need to get a
job but I like to drink too much
become a comedian like in your your set
yeah two birds man did it um did you
ever almost get married was there ever a
point where you almost got where like
that almost happened for you um not like
I about the same as like me thinking
about going to law school you know when
you're like at a certain age and your
friends are like doing real things and
you're like oh like maybe I guess this
is where I just go and go to law school
and become a lawyer yeah you know it's
like oh my friends are all getting
married I've been in a relationship a
long time maybe I will and then I'm like
oh wait no people just do it just cuz
they think it's what they're supposed to
do you think so I think a lot of people
do yeah you just like oh I get married
that's what I do and then you're like 10
years in you're like wait why am I doing
this and now at this point in my life
getting married just seems like a
terrible financial decision yeah it's
just like why I don't I don't know if uh
this makes sense so do you think a lot
of people they just feel like that's
what they have to do it's like I have to
get married now there's it's just what
I'm supposed to do it's like my
responsibility do you think it's to like
family do you think it's just like to
society I'm just wondering because I've
never had like that mindset whatever
that mindset is it's just never been
kind of whatever in my head I think it's
both I think it's family and Society you
know I've got several married siblings
and they're always like when are you
getting married like people when they
get married they want everyone else to
join their crew you have a kid you want
everyone else to have a kid too so you
can talk about having a kid it's like I
not going to have a kid just because you
did and maybe if I lived in like a
suburb somewhere and that was my life
and it was like this I'm this is my
house I'm stay in this house then it's
like all right kids are this is what I'm
going to spend my life doing right be
kid in here there's yeah there's a place
for a kid to be over here we could
definitely put a kid in this area yeah
and I definitely don't want kids really
I even went through a phase where I was
like if it happened I've got money now I
could I could handle this but I had no
real interest in doing it do you think
you'd even have bad luck having kids
because so many kids die in your oh yeah
material it is a thing that I think
about like I've done talked a lot about
sharks and so I would never go surfing
yeah because if I get eaten by a shark
everyone's going to be like see I know
this this is karma he he like he was
this was his fate his whole life that
having a kid seems terrifying and I
think every parent goes through this
once you find out you're pregnant of
like you know so many things can go
wrong yeah you hear about the bad you
hear about the good you know you're
counting the toes and the fingers uh
autism like all kinds of different stuff
that you're just like hoping that just
it seems like nice not to deal with that
stress yeah I don't miss it and you
don't know if your kid's autistic for
like a couple years and stuff I think so
it's
like dude we both know people who are
like for sure autistic and they just un
us yeah yeah undocumented artistic get
out of the country well I think a lot of
I've had a lot of theories that a lot of
the future will be uh people like if you
look at guys like Jeff Bezos right and
Elon Musk and um I'm trying to think of
some other people that seem to me if I'm
listening to them they seem like they
have some sort of autism right like but
but they're also the people that are
able to quantify things to like another
level like to where they can advance
Society like I think it's it's going to
it's getting to the point where those
are the people that are going to have
the skill sets to move us to the next
space in the universe you're always
going to need some of those guys who are
like working on the numbers and [__] you
know you need some people you need some
people who can talk you know need some
people who are like just sitting in back
there crunching numbers but have you
ever tested yourself for
autism no I know that they had they
thought I was down syndrome when I was a
child for a while I had that cuz I was
big for my age oh really I was like
people I look like I was four when I was
like one and a half oh and yeah I heard
a lot I heard a lot of stories about me
in the supermarket especially in
Pittsburgh mhm especially in Pittsburgh
oh yeah cuz all the babies there are
really small you know compared to me I
was a huge huge baby really yeah I was
the biggest baby that had ever been born
in Pittsburgh at the time oh my God and
what did they did they do and what H did
they put a I don't even know did they
give you like a statue what did they
even it was a sash they put on me and
then they put me in like a stroller it
was like a bigger stroller and they
paraded me down the street and people
would just like kind of wave people
wearing Jerome Bettis jerseys out there
this was pretty this is pre-bus oh
really so like Jer shansky Franco I
think probably a lot of Franco jerseys
out there yeah yeah yeah Franco Harris
himself tried to pick me up but I was
too
big dude I love Pittsburgh you do oh bro
my friend used to work at Jack bar my
friend oh yeah I know Jack yeah was a
pit he was a mascot he got busted
hooking up with a I think a underage
woman in like an abandoned swimming pool
or something but he um yeah dude I got
pink eye over there one time and I got
and you loved it the first yeah I got
yeah I got a World sex one time behind
the Giant Eagle over there somewhere I
got invited into a familial sexual kind
of threesome with an some people from
Wheeling West Virginia that were
visiting Wheeling are freaks oh yeah
Freaks and Wheeling they kept saying you
want that Wheeling feeling that's what
they said and I was in like a I was in
like a Mazda I was like I don't think we
can do that in here wait they were in
your car yeah yeah I was giving him a
ride home after a show the girl was cute
and her aunt was with her and and they
um when I stopped to drop them off they
asked they just asked Point Blank if I
wanted to have that Wheeling feeling and
I was like I don't know I didn't know
what it was I didn't know if it was
crime or if it was you know like a rash
or you know I didn't know what the hell
it was or tickling somebody real hard
you know I didn't know what their motus
operandi was or whatever and so I just
didn't do it you know how many
opportunities sexual opportunities do
you think you've turned down because you
just didn't understand the
euphemism oh one time in Baltimore I got
offered a
threesome pretty
sure it was threesome or it was like a
pyramid scheme which
is I don't know if those are similar or
not but it was extremely similar
practically the same thing yeah yeah
yeah so yeah it was outside it was kind
of dark it was at muoy remember that
place yeah yeah so it was over there and
um and yeah I guess I got offered that
oh one time I got into a sexual Endeavor
with two women and this was
in col Columbia Missouri and they um the
one of them was like it looked like one
of those bodybuilders from like like
remember when they would wear the one
the singlet and they would have the
thing they would hold it up and it would
say like a 100 PBS written on it or yeah
you know 140 like at the circus or
whatever one of them was like kind of I
I felt attracted to and the other one
had this kind of like polish kind of
like uh like um bodybuilder Vibe sure
and I got coerced into that and that was
that was intense man see I don't trust
three ways I've never had one I've been
propositioned and been like I don't
believe you yeah like there's a catch
yeah this this is two there's
something's going to happen here yeah
like a random hookup on the road you're
like I'm going to hear from you again
there's no free lunch right there's no
free free lunch you're getting a
follow-up email for sure um and the next
time you're in town they're they're
going to be in the front row being like
right and so threeway is just like two
of those coming at you yeah did it when
you first started out what made you stay
in comedy you think were there times
where you ever going to give up or
you've had success really since you kind
of kicked it off it seems like it took a
couple years uh I found that in the
beginning I'm sure you understand this
that when the first couple years it's
embarrassing to tell someone you're a
comedian oh it's the worst it's almost
like yeah you could be like a lot of
people in my where I'm from they felt
like you were gay you didn't want to
bring a wife home you didn't want to
admit something what are you doing you
know not there's anything wrong with
being gay but there were just you know
that those were some of the things like
oh just tell us what's going on yeah you
know if you have cancer or whatever just
tell us yeah people don't understand
your parents don't understand your
family's like what you're doing what
like why don't you try to be more like
this why don't you do Last Comic
Standing I would hear all the time and
it's like I that's a bad show I don't
want to do that and uh and then I
thought the only thing more embarrassing
than saying I'm a comedian for the first
few years would be saying I used to do
comedy like saying that oh yeah like you
after show someone's like you know I
tried I thought about doing that you're
just like get the [__] out of here yeah
that like I thought that was so
embarrassing that I'm like I'm just
going to will myself to some level of
success and I thought at the time I
thought that meant I would get a writing
job and I would quit stand up and I
would just be a joke writer for the rest
of my life and by the time I finally got
that joke writing job I was like I was
doing well enough at standup that I was
like I just want to do this I don't want
to write for someone else I only I'm the
only one who's going to tell my jokes
why don't I just keep doing this and it
worked out did you not want anybody else
telling your jokes to oh that you just
said it would like if I wrote I wrote
for Sarah Silverman Jimmy Kimmel and
they were like if I loved a joke they
loved it too and they would tell it and
I was so proud to have them tell my joke
no problem with that but then I would
write for Jimmy Fallon and he would say
this is really funny but people are
going to hate me and I'd be like you're
right but I don't care that's fine you
can hate me and still laugh you can't
hate Jimmy and still laugh so it just
didn't work out but I was like oh I'm I
need to just write my own stuff and do
it myself like I've got my own way of
telling the jokes you know that is is
fun oh yeah it's a me it's a horrible
dance you take us on I mean it's it's
marvelous yes I KN I knew what you meant
okay good yeah it's exceptionally hor
it's
like yeah I feel like you I here's I
always feel like it's that same feeling
I get watching you and watching some of
your material when I'm in a haunted
house and I know I'm going to be scared
right I'm walking through something I
know there's something right around the
corner that's F
that's you know and I just keep going
down the road and then next thing you
know um again you got me again thank you
yeah I I consider myself when I describe
it as a horror film like you know you're
in good hands yeah you know you're not
watching a snuff film this is like a
real movie with real actors and at the
end you'll be satisfied and there's
going to be some scares like just enjoy
it it's it's all fun I'm not I don't
have a message just you know nihilism do
you ever did you ever feel like you were
haunted like a lot of people you know
think that people are haunted and stuff
like that did you ever have any
like at a certain point you have to look
at yourself and be like oh well I am
there's something unique you know
there's something very Simon Birch about
me or something you know uh yeah no I um
people ask me that all the time like
because I have a dark sensibility like
you something happened to you and it's
like no I've had a very Charmed Life
like i' I've had a great life my parents
are still together you know there's no
abuse I was always drawn to violence and
and awful things in life it just people
just didn't talk about them and I was
like why not they're so important like
why is this so forbidden why does no one
want to talk about death yeah you know
and as a kid I was shamed for that a lot
of like always being like what about
this and they like stop talking about
that like we don't want to talk about
the Challenger anymore Anthony like it
blew up like you're in first grade just
move on to other things and I I didn't
understand what was unhealthy about it I
thought if the greatest Minds in history
have been sitting there wondering what
happens when we die why is it weird for
a kid to think about it yeah so that
them pushing back on me made me mad and
that anger carried me through my first
10 years of Comedy W and then you get
success and you let go of the anger
you're like okay what do I have left and
it's interest you know it's these topics
interest me and I want to find a way to
make people laugh at them wow that's
interesting man do you think like that
we do it be like do you think a lot of
people do it there's a chip on their
shoulder yes like they want to prove
that
they yeah what what I'm trying to think
of what did I want to prove prove you're
not a [__] loser I feel like when
you're in school it's like you're
ruining not only are you messing up your
your own education but everyone around
you everyone sitting within four desks
is getting a worst grade because they're
near you oh yeah everyone's Furious and
you're like I've got to prove like my on
my high school put me in the uh the Hall
of Fame in Alumni Hall of Fame a few
years ago and I was so proud wow because
I gave a speech and I was like this is
you guys saying you were right yeah you
know like for for 12 years of of high
school they were just like [__] stop
this you're throwing your life away and
I was like watch me like I'm I'm Trust
me I've got a plan and it all worked out
and now they're like great we're proud
that you're from the school and that
took a long time how many though first
of all that's unbelievable did you go
back to the school and they had like
gave you accommodation of sort yeah they
gave they had it was like this this like
little trophy thing like a big glass
like triangle there were like you know
10 other people that all kind of gave
little speeches but I was like I'm the
one who had a TV show with my name in
the title you know like this is this is
my thing this other guy just you know
still plays tennis that's why he's in it
right he's a yeah Sherwin Williams
manager it counts but yeah um wow dude
that's unbelievable did it almost I
wonder if that would make me feel like
so much more rewarded than anything
because that was like the Battlegrounds
of being fun like that was where I feel
like it was the most fun to be funny yes
did you have that experience or no oh
yeah I mean I I couldn't not tell a joke
if I thought of it I'm like this is too
good it's got to go it's going to go to
waste but my thing was trying to make
the teacher laugh oh because if you made
a joke class teacher would yell at you
immediately but if you made her laugh or
him laugh it was always a woman and I
think about it uh then they couldn't get
mad at you and that felt so good because
it was like you knew you did something
wrong but you did it in the best way
possible so now you're the star oh
that's fascinating how how do you not
get in trouble like how like right I
understand you're going to put me in
trouble but you and I know yes and all
these Comics now it's like almost the
point is to get in trouble it's like why
are you giving me [__] I'm I'm a comic
I'm allowed to whatever I want that's
wrong as far as I'm concerned art oh wa
say it again so I don't miss people
think like oh as a comic your job is to
get in trouble and so but they don't
want to get yelled at it's like it's
okay to make people mad but they don't
want any push back and I think that's
wrong as a comedian you want to make
people laugh Andy this is a quote
attributed to Andy Warhol that I love it
just art is getting away with it you
know if you put out a special and
everyone's pissed like you didn't get
away with it you know you need to make
everyone laugh that they're like yeah
you talk to's [__] up stuff but we're
all happy that's
art otherwise you're just a
troll that's fascinating man because it
adds another level to a lot of things
you're like the the Superfluous level
isn't enough you're like I want to go to
this this other level even thinking of
I'm going to get the teacher to laugh I
never have thought about that yeah just
happened one day teacher laughed and I
was like oh I'm not in trouble right now
I would have been what's the difference
oh teacher left wow and it was like it
was a Stern teacher it was a strict
teacher who like never laughed and it
was like oh okay if I can get her I can
do this yeah dude I used to think that
if I stared at my teacher enough that
they would want to have sex you know
really I never I had one there was a we
had a French teacher that sixth grade
who uh French first of all even being
French makes you think they're going to
want to have B seexual totally yeah and
it was a gym teacher oh who was like a
former gymnist was a French gy no she it
was a it was the French teacher she was
American but spoke French and then there
was a gym teacher who was also a
babe or something I think you guys were
doing like you know we did learn the
basics of Cirus solle okay yeah some of
the early stuff
yeah um and she was hot if I as I
remember like I could if she walked in
here right now I wouldn't know who the
hell she was but at the time because a
lot of our teachers were busted you know
dogsville okay not attractive yes so
reals one that was even like remotely
young was like oh my God this is she's a
mermaid yeah we had one that either had
huge breasts or filled her shirt with
something that looked like breast mhm
and she wore like a doily like around
her neck kind of or whatever that little
collar thing was and we were all like
literally D when she came in the room
you could feel like cuz it was like
right around that per uh per when people
was going through per or whatever and
you could feel people didn't even know
how to exist like all the blood would
rush to like your brain like parts of
your like you didn't even know how to
stand it was just God when there was a
cuz teachers are also the first woman
that you're around a lot of times where
you're in the same space it's not your
mother mhm but you're around each other
a lot they're in a position of power so
if they look a little attractive I think
it's like it's can be very sexual for a
lot of young men I mean it's it's a the
crazy fantasy you know like H for
Teacher you know but I think when you're
when you hit puberty as a as a boy they
start to send you to health class you
know it's like they separate the boys
and the girls and they start talking to
you I can't believe they don't just like
put you in jail for 3 years because
everyone everyone from the age of like
11 to like 16 is up to no good it's pure
evil and this is we were before the
internet man yeah like you had to know
someone who had an older brother who had
a Playboy collection yeah and they would
like tear out like a a picture and bring
it to you and I remember someone gave me
one it was just a woman from be she was
just standing up had like a perfect ass
but it was just her ass like her hair
and this is the only picture that I had
this was it and it was like I am I an
ass guy now like I don't know this is
just what you have and now these kids
are just like every little thing every
every fetish every fantasy you could
ever imagine there is at their
fingertips and it's not good I can't
imagine in 10 years shit's going to go
down like it's going to be everyone's
going to have a Sex Dungeon it's going
to be crazy wild [__] and we no one's
going to be able to keep up oh
I think uh oh yeah I remember somebody
even give you a picture of a regular
chick and they'd write like hot [__] on
it or something you'd think you like oh
this is and she wasn't even naked it's
just like that somebody had written that
I remember when someone told me about
the p word and I just couldn't
even I felt so ashamed that I didn't
know it I felt like I didn't know how to
communicate anymore like the world was
passing me by cuz like some guy's like
you don't know what the you know he
would say you know I don't like saying
it that much but he would say like you
don't know what he means you know and
I'd be like do you not like saying the
word because of like the combination of
letters or you don't like calling
someone that like would you have a
problem calling a guy a [__] or you
just don't want to describe the anatomy
as I think if a guy only had like One
Wing or something and we're and he's
hungry and he only then I would might
say something like that but I don't
think I like s cuz I don't want people
to hear it if they're listening
somewhere and they don't feel
comfortable hearing it I think it's
probably thought about it that's your
fan base people who can't hear the word
[__] I think it's people that probably
I don't I don't want them to hear it
that much I don't care if they hear it
once in a while but I think that it yeah
I try not to put that out there too much
with my audience I feel like I want them
to hear it from me you know it's like
I'm a trusted Source I don't want them
hearing it out on the street from random
randos you know I'm the authority figure
[__] yeah yeah yeah that's a good see
at least so confident about it yeah yeah
I think I didn't oh I remember somebody
was like you oh they said you don't know
what a dildo is some kid in fifth grade
and I didn't right and I could never
handle not knowing what like I didn't
want to be somebody that didn't know
something right it was like real control
thing I think like controlling my
environment and when I didn't know and
then I was on the school bus and I
didn't know and I just called the bus
driver it you know I was like I'm going
to take my chances and see what this is
and it did not go good and I had to go
to the principal that's when they still
would spank you and his fell Lon mcke
was his name and he gave me a couple
good Lashes in his office this episode
is sponsored by
Blue if you're Wiener's DN baby down and
out then you can uh give it that second
chance that Revival baby that's blue
chew they'll do it bring the Heat this
winter with that BC baby that blue Cho
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Calis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost baby cheat baby get that Winger
dancing for cheat Bubba you know what
I'm talking about
bluechew we got a special deal for our
listeners try bluechew free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
$5 shipping and I'll Chomp into them
I'll have half of one if I'm going
anywhere to the carnival wherever that's
bluechew.com promo code Theo to receive
your first month free visit
BL
cw.com for more details and important
safety information we thank blue for
sponsoring the podcast wayer if you've
been in a car accident or you've been
hit by something if you've had something
fall on you or your body you've had a
missw workk well if any of those things
are part of your life Morgan and
Morgan can help Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury Law Firm if
you've been injured if you need a neck
brace a leg brace or something they can
do it Morgan and Morgan has over 100
offices Nationwide more than 800
lawyers with over $15 billion doll
recovered for clients Morgan and Morgan
has a proven track record of fighting to
get you full and fair compensation
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a
lawyer that's it if you're ever injured
you can check out Morgan and Morgan
their fee is free unless they win for
more information go to forthepeople.com
SL this past weekend or dial pound law
that's pound 5 29 from your cell phone
that's
fthe
people.com this past weekend or dial
pound
529 from your sell this is a paid
advertisement remember one year I think
I was in second grade or the principal
of my elementary school was named Dr
broy broy broy is that French or what is
it I don't he certainly was not French
but I don't know what it was but I'm in
second I'm seven or eight years old and
I have like a Sharpie or a pen and I
write on the back of the bus seat Dr
butt
guy yeah and which to me I thought was
really funny and some kid behind me told
the bus driver was like he's riding on
the seat and the guy comes back and sees
it and then takes me off the bus and
into the principal's office and they're
like you wrote on the back of the bus
and it's Dr bro guy being like what did
you write and I'm like I just Doodles
just I just kind of just a little
drawing and they the bus driver's like
come on the bus and see oh me and Dr Bry
had to go and look at Dr but guy that
was a tough one I liked going to the
office in a little bit cuz it was like
let to your first business meeting I
think when you were a kid it terrified
me like I like knowing what I know now I
would have been like fine like it's a
break from class but then I was like I'm
in so much trouble I in my heart I must
have thought I was getting expelled
every time and then my parents were
going to kill me and my parents were
always mad at me about school like I'm
not applying myself enough I'm like I'm
getting in trouble were they really
smart your parents they were they both
very smart and knew I was smart like I
have other sibling I'm the oldest of
five and they didn't get the same
pressure that I got it was like oh
you're the last of five I was the oldest
of five oldest of five so I was the
first one through and they were just
like all our teachers are telling us
you're smarter than this you you just
don't try and I drove them crazy
everyone I was like I got better grades
than my siblings but they were like yeah
but they're they're doing their best
like you're not so that that drove them
nuts so every time I went to the
principal for whatever I would have I
would have been happy if they hit me in
in uh in school but they didn't they
would just tell your parents and that
was way worse my parents didn't hit me
either but uh I didn't like the
disappointment I would have taken a
beating yeah I'm trying to think if I
yeah my mom would beat us pretty good
how many siblings do you have I got
three siblings and my brother's older
and I got two younger sisters but we
were not close there was not any
affection in our home like we didn't
know nobody had any feelings it was very
much felt like a business kind of where
you were like an employee for like very
lowlevel allowance that you never even
got mhm there was always some reason you
didn't get it and uh that's what it felt
like it felt like a very it felt like a
little bit of a pyramid scheme is what
it kind of our family felt like Theo do
you know what a pyramid scheme
is yeah it's
like it's like when
you offer you tell some you get you say
to somebody do you want to
get like a
couple uh shares of do you want to get
shares of like a
um what do you think it is I think some
of the top is like you pay me and then
you get but for paying me you get to
come in and then people below you are
going to pay you and the money's going
to flow up oh yeah so you get you get
involved and then you help people more
people get involved it wasn't like that
it was not that yeah it was more like
kind of trickle down maybe some type of
Reaganomics or something it was
something it was something that wasn't
working families weren't Fair like I
feel like my my family we never talked
about money ever it was just assumed
that we had it and you would just be
told yes or no if you wanted something
okay and then now they say that families
you should tell your kids like here's
how much dad makes here's how much mom
makes here's what the budget is here's
what the house costs that way you know
how much so you're not always asking for
things that I think is very smart
whereas my family was like no you can't
have that but I didn't know why and then
I grew up and was like oh we were just
we had less money than all all the kids
around us you know the people around us
had more money for different reasons
that either had different jobs or or a
fewer kids but uh but I I just assumed
we had everything and my parents just
didn't want to give it to us you know
God that's an insane thought yeah it's
so maob really yeah I like oh they're
just being mean I can't get a Nintendo
and I was like no we we're trying to pay
our mortgage
like yeah why else as a kid you don't
understand like do you I got a dog and
my dog only wants to like play eat like
walk and he doesn't understand why we're
not doing those things it's like playing
is so much fun let's go play and I'm
like oh I once you kind of understand
that yeah that like Simplicity like Okay
and like kids are like that they just
want to consume they just want eat pizza
for every meal and like hot dogs and go
to baseball games they don't understand
why as an adult you don't want to do
that yeah do you think like you were a
good brother when you were growing up or
not no I was the oldest of five and it
was five kids in seven years and I just
wanted to do my own thing I wasn't prot
I was protective of my sisters but only
as much as I had to be right so you did
you buy into the family system or were
you very much like I'm doing like I'm
doing my own thing I was like I don't
want to I don't want have to do I don't
want to mow the lawn I don't want to do
any of this
stuff all free agents yeah I'm doing my
own thing and then when I left for
college then we became closer it was
like the little distance coming back we
all kind of we're closer in age now I
mean was same level and age my brother
who was you know born when I was seven
years old is now like my favorite person
in the world you know so yeah we're
really close what's kind of interesting
about that like do you like being like
now do you like see more value in being
a brother what's kind of interesting cuz
I I I have a brother and
you know we weren't close when we're
kids but now I love having a brother
it's like the best thing uh it's it's
just it's hard when they're seven years
you're seven years apart like I wanted a
brother so badly from like the moment I
like have Consciousness and I got three
sisters every two years I get another
sister and I just like wanted one and I
finally got that brother and I was like
oh I he can't do anything like he's
useless until like for a long time and
then by the time I like I went to
college when I was 18 you know he was 11
so like now we were very very close but
I think it's just having being closer in
age I think if he was like two years
younger than me we'd be much much closer
is he a Steelers fan yes wow you
Pittsburgh you have to be yeah yeah it's
tough this year but uh it's been Rocky
man I wanted to buy in uh pick it right
and I say you know y all I think party
always cheers for the Steelers I mean
cuz I'm a Saints fan and they're black
and gold Steelers are black and gold and
I love Steelers you know I you know I'd
always go up there you hear all these
crazy rumors about Cordell Stewart and
Shenley Park you'd hear all of this you
know you people's just saying tank you
know you'd hear all of it you know
um and so yeah I always want them to do
well but and then I saw him with that
mustache and I'm like this means he's
going to do well cuz you don't grow a
mustache I think unless you're planning
on doing something where I'm from yeah
and and then he just hasn't been able to
really put it together yet I think he
hasn't been that bad I think it's like I
think it's everybody I don't think like
everyone's like it's the coaching I'm
like no it's it's not just the players
it's everyone just kind of just being a
little bit off I think we'll pull it
together I think we'll we'll be you know
a game over 500 maybe game under maybe
break Tomlin streak but I'm the kind of
fan who I just want to support I'm I
like the coaches I like the players like
if they get traded like I still like
them I'm just I just happy that the team
is there I don't get mad yeah you know I
don't get mad about the Steelers anymore
I used to and then I kind of just
realized like this is stupid why am I
ruining like
relationships with people like there was
a game once I think I just moved to LA
and the Steelers played the Patriots it
was the year that Brady won his for
Super Bowl when they had like beaten the
Raiders was a miracle and the Steelers
were really heavily favored and then we
just got crushed and all my friends were
at my place and they were all Patriots
fans except for me oh and I got hammered
and like yelled at everybody like it was
such an embarrassing game and I snapped
that I was so embarrassed that I
couldn't talk to my friends for like a
week and then I was like I'm never doing
this again I'm going to be on emotional
lock down for for sporting events from
now on it's just it's stupid stupid you
put a lot into it yeah and you see
people put their whole lives into it and
they cart their wife out there and
they'll paint their wife the colors of
the team and they'll do all of that you
know what got me uh remember when the
Red Sox won their first World Series in
like forever you know was like early mid
2000s or something and I remember being
pumped for them I had a bunch of friends
who are Red Sox fans and I was rooting
for them to win that year and then after
they won I was happy and then the next
season the fans were like the same ass
it was like they the guy from momento
who doesn't know he killed the dude and
he's just like I got to kill this guy
it's like you killed him you already won
and they didn't didn't bring them that
much joy that I don't want to be that
kind of fan yeah I want to just always
be happy for my team yeah I think that's
what I'm I I I I've struggled to have
that I realize it's like am I a fair
weather fan I was a Die Hard Saints fan
growing up die hard I remember when I
didn't have any money I made like Saints
merchandise and I go out there and sell
bootleg merchandise you know and I loved
them you know
yeah I love the Saints and it just uh
but at a certain point it just I don't
know also got a little bit older I think
you start to realize like I'm bus I
maybe my life I got busier too I didn't
have as much time to do fantasy I don't
know I never I never done fantasy I've
never wanted to really I never want to
root for anyone who's not a stealer I
never want to be like oh you know Calvin
Ridley just you know ran all over us but
he's on my he's on my fantasy team so
I'm happy about that like I never wanted
to do that wow you're really pure then
you're kind of a purist and I also just
don't want to like type in all that [__]
I don't want to sit there for the draft
you know like one of my best friends is
like one of the uh like a big fantasy
football guy like knows everything would
if he ran your team you would win and I
just I would never give a [__] not my
thing I don't gamble do you gamble you
put money on Sports I do gamble
sometimes I realized recently that I
need to kind of chill out you know not a
lot I'll bet like a couple hundred
dollars here and there on something I've
never bet $11,000 on something but um um
I do realize it's like I'm getting a
little like when I get like testy or
bored I want to do something you know
you need to misbehave I'm like that
where I'm like yes like I'm like I don't
I haven't had to drink in like a year
and a half I don't consider myself so I
don't consider myself sober but I
haven't been drinking but I need
something I need like a nicotine pouch
or like some sort of like thing that's
like this is my misbehaving yeah watch
me misbehave where does that come from
that's something I've always had you
think that's just a ma not a malady but
just a St you know a piece of human
like like do you think it's just
something that you that's in you you
know or do you think sorry they got bugs
in here because I think a lot of this
stuff is outdated um we're in a masonic
temple by the way we're this isn't all
new stuff we're in
the is this yeah I think this is not
this isn't the room my show is in but I
think I'm in this theater tomorrow yeah
yeah you are we're in there tonight okay
yeah cool so we're switching awesome um
yeah stavos hos have you ever seen this
kid I know who he is but I haven't met
him thicker kid nice kid he's Viet he's
not Vietnamese what is he white and he
um he's performing in town too tonight
there's a real I mean comedy's it's
everywhere it's everywhere now and I
think it's we're in this phase I think
the second boom is over I think it ended
with the pandemic but there we're in
this like rockar phase where there's
like like you know 5% of the stand-up
comedians are just [__] rock rock
stars and everyone else is like just
kind of tolling away at clubs but I I'll
ride this wave as long as it goes I mean
the fact that there's three comedians in
town this weekend performing at theaters
is kind of crazy you know I mean almost
every weekend I'm out in the road it's
like there's someone that same night
somewhere else it's just I think
probably a lot of it's the pandemic
people were like itching to get out in
the road also people were coming out to
shows man I think it's we're also you
can't get Fair new I mean the news seems
to be to me really compromis these days
right like no matter what news you get
like I learned last week that you can
pay like some of these websites like
billboard or some of them you can pay
them money to come out and like take
photos of you and put them on the
Internet or write a story you can just
pay for it yeah and it's like the news
has been monetized right where it's not
a service anymore and now it's like we
we just need to give you your news right
and that's there should be like just at
the end of the day like here's here's
what really happened yeah right there
should be like some dude who sneaks over
like hey bud let me get five minutes of
your time this is what's going on yeah
this is actually what happened whatever
your politics are like this is what went
down black and white make your own
decisions so I think people are coming
to see something live too because they
want to hear things that they they want
to hear something that's not that
doesn't maybe feel as bought and paid
for do you think that's possible I think
the edges have been sanded off
everything like the every time Disney
buys another company I'm like Oh my
career's gotten shorter if Disney owns
everything I'm never never working again
in television because they they would
never put someone like me on TV it's
like these companies that have to they
have all these responsibilities to just
bad entertainment it's like we just
don't want to make anyone mad you know
it's not about like doing something
great so I think standup it's like the
one place where you can go and just see
an unfiltered not by I don't think it's
like it's edgier uh but I I just think
you have like fewer people worried about
what's going to happen and then you just
want to see an artist like doing their
thing instead of like a hundred artists
and a corporation combining to come up
with a storyline for a season you know
just I think TV and movies have gotten
bad you were one of the first guys that
I heard of that takes like breaks in
their life and touring I don't know if
that's true I would just hear this is
like some of the jelick lore that would
go around I mean there was all kind of
things there was the blood you know the
drink the plasma there was all that kind
of [__] but there was like there was um
that yeah Anthony takes like he'll take
like a month or two often just go
somewhere and do something and spend
time with them by himself or go Trav you
know but it would usually be a writing
Retreat like I would be going to write
like I I'm just going to I got to go
away and lock myself in a cabin and
write a 100 jokes like I would be like
in a week I got to write a 100 no matter
when I do it but I got to leave here
with 100 jokes I remember the one time I
did that I went up and got a place in
ohigh and I wrote a 100 jokes in a week
I was writing on Fon at the time and I
couldn't write my own stuff so I was
like I'm just going to take a week and
go do this and of all those jokes of a
hundred jokes one of them made it into
my act and it was like a 30 second joke
that I was like this was probably a bad
use of my time but I was I I always feel
like I don't know how if you feel about
this but you have to get the bad jokes
out to get to the good jokes you know
let's say like but when you start doing
comedy you're going to write a million
jokes in your life let's say 200 of them
are going to be great but you still need
to write a million you can't just write
200 and stop that I'm always like I'm
always trying to write just to get the
bad ones out you know so that the good
ones can come to me yeah do that guys
you know yeah like uh who was that oh
Louis CK I was talking with him and he
said what did he say he said uh it's the
ones you don't want to tell a lot of
times like the ones that'll sit there
that you're afraid to tell he's like for
him anyway he said those are the ones
that end up being becoming his favorite
so I love that he says things like that
like I remember he did SNL one year and
he was like there was one sketch that I
was like I hate this it's so stupid we
have to do it like I want to do
something where I'm like I have to blow
a big horn and I feel stupid doing it
because that's what SNL is to me like I
want to do this that to have where he
would talk about like opening with this
closer and then being like how do I
build I've got to go somewhere like I
have to work it out on stage I thought
that was like very brave and an
intelligent way to do it when it comes
to trying out jokes like that though I
always say only try the ones you like
and only keep the ones they like you
know because if you try one you don't
like and the audience loves it you're
stuck with that [__] thing yeah
that's true like I don't have I never
have self-deprecating jokes but I had
one in my act like a couple tours ago
and my openers would laugh cuz they were
like you're just having fun and all of a
sudden you tell this joke and then
you're like mad at the audience for
laughing like the joke was on me and
just annoyed me I hated I hated
self-deprecating comedy no thank you
yeah I don't know if I I like it or not
I don't know I mean I think yeah I think
I'm kind of fine with it I don't know I
think for me A lot of times it feels
like just survival like how do I survive
through this hour mhm with this group of
people to get some high that I need or
something that I need that I've always
needed and I just how do we get to the
end of this with me with it being a fair
exchange MH that's my biggest thing I
want it to be fair for their money that
they spend and fair for what I give them
you know and then I start to look deeper
sometimes like why do people come to see
things what do we look for and people
that we go to watch or that we let
entertain us like what I'm putting put
my own attention on you know that seems
to be the biggest thing that I have the
the thing I have the mo of my own value
seems to be like my attention like where
do I let it sit where do I who do I give
it to you know I find those like
websites sometimes that I'll go to I'm
like why am I giving this it doesn't
even feel good it doesn't feel rewarding
you know yeah like the Tik Tok and [__]
where you're just like an hour goes by
and you're like what am I I haven't
learned anything or I just feel like
I've burned an hour yeah yeah yeah some
of I laugh and stuff but it's like
Facebook you know I'll go and look and
see if anybody's dead from high school
you know and I hate to say that but it's
like that's kind of it you know if
there's like a good raffle that
somebody's doing I'll do that but it's
like I don't like what am I am I here
just because I'm being lazy and then I
start to look like at the algorithm it's
like man they've got us really on the
ropes as far as to us just becoming
humans just
becoming
like trained completely trained fish it
feels oh dude it's going to be like the
[__] end of Wall-E remember that
movie it's like all the the fat people
in the the wheelchairs like and I think
we're going to I think you and I will be
okay it's the younger kids that I'm like
oh they're all [__] like they just
their attention span is gone I don't
even know what the world's going to look
like in 50 years when they're running it
like I think about the people who are in
Tech you know they have kids now and
they all have nannies and [__] and their
one rule is keep the kids off the
tablets right they don't want them to
have a phone an iPad anything and
everyone else is like here you go like
see you in see you when you're 18 and
they're the ones making the [__] that's
the thing and that's so they know how
dangerous is they know how bad it is but
it it seems like a bad way to you know
experience your childhood is to always
have stuff like remember you'd run home
from school run home to catch the
cartoons you had to like Sprint upstairs
to the bathroom and come back down
before the the commercials were over to
catch the second half of Dukes of Hazard
like you had like where you were
mattered and now everything is just at
your finger fingertips and I think it's
bad for you oh I think the value of most
things it's like I think about this like
even with relationships and stuff like
the light in a woman's eyes you got to
see it used to be that was from your W
you know was like or the that was from
your partner was like that's who you you
know that was the war but now it's like
there's just constantly you know it's
like you can find anything of somebody
just completely giving everything they
have to a screen somewhere and I just
wonder what the effect of that is on
like marriages and like like and if you
go look on your phone all day and
stuff's making you laugh then if you get
home and your kid makes you laugh right
I'm not saying that it your kid doesn't
still make you laugh but does it like
debilitates does it take away a little
bit of that CU your dopamine has been
slowly released all day yeah that by the
time you get home you're like oh I've
seen 40 attractive women on social media
I've seen like some kid in you know uh
Miami or some you know they find a kid
in the dirt like in Uganda or something
and he's happy or whatever he's got a
diamond or whatever and he's all ple you
know it's like you've seen the happiest
kid in the world for the day so it's I
just wonder are we do we cannibalize
have we just cannibalized every thing
that used to have meaning right and not
just like to hit a dopamine for your
head but like some meaning to you
intrinsically like as a human you know I
think it's taken away a little bit of
community because you everyone has their
own entertainment that's just for them
on demand so you don't like watch things
together that's why like this summer
going to see Barbie and Oppenheimer with
like a theater full of people dressing
up was like such a crazy thing that
hasn't been happening for a while
because people would just sit at their
sit at home you everyone's watching the
same videos but at different times on
their phone by themselves so they might
like pass them around but you don't just
sit and like you know if people threw up
10 minutes of memes at the office every
morning and they sat in an office and
laughed at them and everything great but
everyone's just kind of just in their
own [__] absorbing them yeah at their
own time and F it's just like I think
that's a that's a big part of it and
we've talked about that before we had a
guy on here named John Veri and he's
like a meaning specialist so or he's not
like a specialist but he's like a
professor and that's what man's quest
for meaning that's what a lot of his
stuff is about and he talks about like
the stoics and like Aristotle and like
the past and how man has always searched
for meaning kind of but a lot of he
talks about his shared experiences
that's one of the biggest things that we
had as humans like um is that we share
experiences yeah would all I remember we
would all watch a show then we would go
out in the street if we watched In
Living Color and we would go in the
street in our neighborhood and
impersonate all the characters dude
like way like oh homie to clown homie
dude we would and it was like and if you
could do it good in the street it like
there was but we'd all seen it and it
was just so yeah if you'd seen a new
episode had come out and you'd have
you'd be like when the commercial break
came on you'd piss and have to get back
before the right before the commercial
ended oh yeah that Monday morning in
school everyone that's all anyone's
talking about yeah like I was I was hu
big into comedy as a kid and I remember
when I got to college remember Mr Show
with Bob and David I've heard of that
show David Cross Bob Odenkirk and I
loved it it was like edgy like hard
comedy it was on like midnight on a
Friday no one ever watched it and I
would make my friends come over i' like
I'm buying the beer I've got the weed
just come and just watch this thing with
me and they all hated it and I was just
sitting there just trying to make them
like you don't think this is it was so
[__] funny to me Ben the Ben Stiller
show when I was in like eth grade every
Monday I was like did you guys watch
this it was so [__] funny and no one
it wasn't like they didn't think it was
funny they didn't even know about it and
weren't interested about it like I was
always just extra into comedy because it
was a way to bond with people you know
I'm doing you're doing the theater and
2,000 people all laughing at the same
time and it's like this is awesome this
is great that we get I get to just see
this it's cool do you ever sometimes
wish sometimes I wish I was the guy in
the audience having a good time you ever
wish that does that make any sense I I
know exactly what you mean and I feel
like I'm like I'm past it like I can't
enjoy comedy the way that I used to I
would love to go back and the way that I
would experience comedy back in the day
but now I just know too much about it I
see too much that I'm just like oh okay
like I just I watch it different like I
opened for Chris Rock in Europe a few
years ago wow he's my favorite he's
amazing I mean maybe the greatest to
ever do it and a guy that I was like I'm
absolutely going to learn everything I
can I'm going to watch him every night
watch his whole set watch everything and
after two shows I was like he's a
[__] genius like what I'm not I can't
take anything from him on on stage
there's nothing I can take that would be
that would like be okay to take it's
like he's got this Cadence he's got
these things he's worked on but I just
became obsessed with like how does he
prepare what does he do right after he
gets off stage what does he do right
before what's his process like because
it's like I can learn from that but he's
just too great of a standup to to take
anything from him on
stage yeah I think I watching certain
guys fem Amir when I watch him I love
he's so funny great he's so everybody
loves him I don't think there's one type
of like he's so funny oh he's just the
nicest guy too so many Comics like nice
is a low bar in comedy you know it's
like I he didn't like actively assault
me he's like a nice guy but someone who
actually you want to sit and talk to and
can enjoy a conversation is few and far
between and he's he's one of those guys
dude there was a comedian one night over
at The Comedy Store where some guy's
backing out of The Comedy Store hits a
woman with his car right a like a
woman's car or a woman hit a woman a
human woman wow
and uh which I don't condone no and so
huh can't do it yeah I mean and the guy
so then he takes off into the building
right a few minutes later I I just see
it from the porch I'm like what and it
wasn't really hard but it was the lady
fell down right and people were
stripping out and the guy like seven or
eight minutes later he I'm in the back
other part of The Comedy Store he comes
up to me he's like hey dude he has no
idea I've seen it he's like do I look
like I just hit a woman with my car and
I'm like what
what what would that look like I don't
know but I don't know if he was on drug
or if somebody he was like hey man do I
look like I just hit a woman with my car
and I was like n man you look totally
chill yeah do you think he was going to
like walk out there and like oh that
can't be him thinking yeah we're brought
to you by manscaped that's right
manscape you got to escape that man boy
you got to damn you got to uh
incorporate that dragon baby you got to
you got to get your body right and get
your body Shor well baby you're one of
God's sheep baby manscaped has taken a
step up from just doing your balls to
get your face the cleanest shave it's
ever seen so this season no need to toil
and trouble manscapes all new
handyman is the best way to get rid of
that stubble featuring a compact design
and Next Generation Skin safe
technology the handyman will give you
that smooth finish without the mess of a
traditional shave get the sweetest treat
this Halloween by going to manscaped.com
and use code Theo for 20% off plus free
shipping that's right that's 20% off
with with free shipping at manscaped.com
and use code Theo for a look as sweet as
candy get yourself the handyman from
manscaped are you struggling with
keeping your website up to date and
running your business
well now you can binge all the web
design and digital marketing you want
with modify that's right modifies
unlimited web design and redesigns
unlimited website updates 247 support
and help with digital
advertising plus you get your own
designated designer that's modify mod
phy for website design considering
updating your existing website or
getting a new one modify can help visit
modify. Theo for 50% off the last
website you'll ever need that's M
oy.com
Theo for 50% off the last website you'll
ever need today's episode is brought to
you by better help does it feel like
your brain's going to hell sometimes
does it feel like your thoughts or have
been
um vultured over by Satan by negativity
by uh your own uncomfort well better
help can help you you know if you just
don't feel like you're on track I've
been there I've felt negative I've felt
down in the dumps I felt um like it's so
cold in the D you know what I'm saying
and what helped me was better help
better help therapy
they will do it and they can do it for
you if you've benefited from therapy if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
that's what's great about it it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge make your brain your friend with
better help
visit betterhelp.com theot today to get
10% off your first month that's better
hp.com
EO but comments are strange man it's
really crazy to think how many strange
people get together in building in how
much like like I was thinking yesterday
about how Brody Stevens took his life
right like that's crazy because we so
many of us had seen him that night and
there's nothing about him that seemed
very errone or you know like people knew
that he was struggling you never kind of
knew what level he was struggling at
because I think he put so much of it
also into his act so you were never sure
how much was an act and how much wasn't
no I mean people who were like the most
depressed put on the best mask you know
it's like you ever see those memes it's
like this isn't the face of depression
someone being like crying it's like it's
somebody's like like it's the smile's
too big you know it's like no one's that
[__] happy man what's going on not
like Brody was always a ball of sunshine
but I mean I was shocked and gutted when
that happened and most of the time I
remember Robin Williams I was like this
[__] guy this [__] guy who like
everyone thinks is the funniest person
of all time like I know had had to pull
the plug like that was gutting that I
I'm not uh I understand that everyone
dies and deaths rarely bother me but
suicide is always just devastates me
like I got to take the afternoon to like
process call the therapist and just like
talk it out because it's always it's
always brutal Brody was a tough one yeah
yeah I think he was so big too he was so
much bigger than life I I think what
scares me the most about it is that it's
like could that happen of something me
could that happen you know how do you go
from seeming just like every other
comedian at the store in a way not I
mean of course you're individual but
just seeming like every other comedian
to
suddenly you know like does something
can something happen in your brain that
just makes that happen yes I mean
suicide and read a book about this last
year I think uh amazing book was just
like suicide is almost like a state of
mind like it's like it's just like
something comes over you and you can't
you can't help yourself like you're not
you're not who you normally were and a
lot of times if a friend of mine or
someone I know uh you know dies by
Suicide I like I have to know the
details like I need to know what
happened was it Financial was it like I
was reading a book where if people try
to kill themselves by jumping off a
bridge into water if they do it over uh
romantic entanglements if if they do it
over a woman or a guy they almost always
if they don't die when they hit the
water swim to the surface they're like
what am I doing this is so stupid I and
they they swim out and they get saved if
they're if they're jumping over
financial [__] they sink like a stone
just like thank God this is over like
it's just these different things get
into people's minds and just extinguish
any sort of any sort of flame there's a
book about that mhm oh wow
yeah yeah I just don't know I wonder if
I have too much of an ego that's why I
wouldn't like ego is so interesting cuz
it's like kind of this Shadow but it's
like
this I don't know do when you say ego do
you mean like your your body saying like
you know not today or do you mean like
your in your mind being like I'm not
going to let people read about me
tomorrow that I took my own life that's
what I think I or I don't want to die
yeah you know I don't want to die this
is all I'm doing is being alive so if if
I die it's probably going to be pretty
boring you know know at least if I'm
alive I can do any you know the things
are possible I feel like death sounds
great it's just like you get to sleep
like I don't sleep that well so like the
idea of just like you go to sleep
forever sounds awesome suicide I'm not
going out like that I'm not doing that
to people who knew me I'm not going to
be that's not going to be the end of my
story and I just like refuse that I
never even entertain it uh but I'm am
fascinated by uh by
it yeah yeah I just don't and I don't
know how I would do it I just don't know
if I could do I don't want to do it I
would do like the guy in the garage with
the piping or whatever probably
something casual yeah I us I used to
think that I'd be like okay I'd be like
a bathtub guy you know kind of thing
would take some pills and go to sleep
and then I would read about it more and
it was like men don't do that men pull
out the shotgun men jump off a thing you
know like women take the pills women go
in the bathtub and I was like oh well
this isn't for me you know I'm not going
I'm not going out
pansy style yeah you know what I mean oh
yeah look I yeah I was raised by my mom
so I used to wear that towel I would put
it up around my chest sometimes you know
what I'm talking about like the bath
towel yeah and then one day my buddy's
like I was at my buddy's house he's like
dude what the [__] are you doing yeah
like you have the towel like above your
breast or whatever and and I remember
sometimes I would stand and I would talk
like I remember if I was talking to
somebody with my shirt off I would cover
my chest like this like just the nipples
or like the whole yeah like the nipples
I just remember it was probably
something that my mom did if she was
like you know if we peaked in her room
or something and she'd like what do you
you know like I don't know it just
seemed kind of it seemed like more of a
feminine trait you know I remember when
I was a kid like we do yard work at the
house and I was helping always helping
my dad you know because uh I was the
oldest and it was just like it's hot out
take your shirt off like take your shirt
off we're out we're doing yard work and
I was like great and one day I'm like
playing football with my friends who are
like eight or nine years old and it's
really hot and I just take my shirt off
to play and they all just like stop and
look at me like what the [__] [__] are
you doing and I was like oh got it shirt
back on like never again like I'm not a
shirt off guy yeah in our neighborhood
taking your shirt off was a sign of
respect when I was growing up what like
if somebody did
something you know we had people that
couldn't real you know speak really well
and
very you know just damn limited you know
and so people would take their shirt off
as like a sign of like
um like respect you know like we're with
this guy you know I remember that like
on like you're watching 911 you're just
like everybody take your shirts off no
no know it be something more localized
like if you were watching like uh like
if somebody had started like a ditch
fire or something and you
know people were supporting him or
whatever he was doing if he was burning
like their if it was a woman burning her
husband stuff or whatever or something
if you were doing if you were in support
of whoever was doing something there was
like a it was almost like I don't know
what to say so I'm just going to say
that I'm a I am showing myself here so
very it's felt very primitive when I
think back on it you take the shirt off
and you're done or you swinging it
around or you throwing the shirt away
like this shirt's done now I saw
something so cool but you just hold it
until yeah you just hold it you say like
I'm here and then this moment of respect
is over 10 minutes 15 minutes you put
the shirt back on yeah things would kind
of dissipate or something I think
somebody you know the oldest kid will
put their shirt back on and then the
rest of the kids would put their shirt
back on so it was like a it was an age
thing I think it was like a
um yeah it was something but I just
remember that if you didn't know what to
do you just took your shirt off if you
around an adult sometimes you took it
you know just to show it was like a sign
of respect
somehow I just remember people doing it
a lot I always think it's funny when you
see like you see fights online like I
follow Twitter account it's like here's
a fight and it's like it's the worst
just some door some like random guy in
the suburbs rips his shirt like they
start arguing tears his shirt off and
starts flexing always makes me laugh why
do they allow these children you ever
see the fights of children beating up
other children online why do they allow
that to be on it seems like we created a
culture that is just imitating what they
see right because at a certain point you
just see the same it's like the same
exact video just new people and I'm like
why shouldn't there be a
block that's where I get weird about
like free speech kind of I guess you
know it's like shouldn't there be a BL
lock that lets us not see this the fight
the kids fighting yeah I just think it's
like cuz then some kid sees that now 20
other kids are going to go make the
video yeah like are we just perpetuating
it you know I don't know I I mean there
were plenty of fights before that this
started happening I don't know if
anyone's fighting for the video you
almost hope you it's the kind of fight
that doesn't like that isn't going to be
online like I would got in a the last
time I got in a real fist fight I think
it was like a sophomore in high school
and they filmed it they had a camcorder
on ack tripod what and filmed it and I
won the fight was it Comedy
Central with the uh like was it a
company that filmed the fight yeah when
I was 16 years old Oh I thought you you
said high school high school yeah oh
sorry high school and uh just the the
guy thought he was going to beat me up
and had his friends film it and I won
the fight and yeah and people passed the
tape around I did one of the coolest
things I've ever done before or since I
was this guy's bigger than me and I'm
not winning this fight in the beginning
and we get to a point we've both thrown
a couple punches and he gets me from
behind he's like got me in like a bear
hug around my arms oh and he's trying
he's trying to like throw me down and I
just in this Mo in this like 5-second
span I remember a movie called bird on
Bird on wire with Mel Gibson B on wire
on wire Goldie H yes with Goldie Han and
Mel Gibson's thing in that movie his
move and when you fight was to someone
would get him from behind and he would
put his head forward and slam his head
back and so I just let my all my body
weight go like I just went limp and have
my head Dro down and then slammed it
back and caught him right in the head
and he went down and you hear everyone
scream and I was just like and like I I
think I knocked his teeth out he had
fake teeth in the first FL and I hit him
and the teeth came out and then he was
like this is over I gotta fix my teeth
and that that tape went around school
for like three weeks and I felt like a
God and then all a sudden it disappeared
but I was like if that was online I
don't
know what my life would have been like
you know you would have been somebody
whose fights I probably that would have
been my thing yeah I'm going to get in a
fight and hope this guy grabs me from
behind and then I'm going to do my Mel
Gibson head snap and this is my identity
now oh you'd be doing a musical of it
for sure I mean that's the kind of thing
that happens it's like
people yeah everything you have to take
it to the stage
now
um have you been to uh mother have you
done comedy Mothership yet no I actually
I was in Austin a few weeks ago and I
had like I had like three shows uh but
then I went I remember Curtis from
Comedy Store yeah he's like running down
he was like hey yeah he's awesome Curtis
Nelson yeah he Curtis was like just come
over uh after your show and like weon be
closed but I'll give you a tour that's
exactly what he did showed me all like
the memorability on the walls and like
showed me the stages and like it all
seems you know pretty uh pretty perfect
performer yeah I think one thing that
they're doing well one thing I noticed
when I was there I just I think I done
maybe two sets there right but it's nice
I mean when you go there like you know
if if you do do a set there they you
know they just surprise the audience
with you so it like you could just
they're just amped you know so that
always feels pretty nice I think and to
be a place where a comedian open to
Comedy Club I think is kind of
interesting and that they get paid
better right that's one thing I think is
really cool I like it that I mean is
that the comedians get paid better I I
root for that place I root for there's
no Comedy Club I root against but it
just seems like it's probably a little
bit
easier there oh because it's kind of
like the a builtin like this like a lot
of the audience that likes like like a
Rogan audience or a Hing Cliff audience
team it's a built-in approval like you
you you're not Joe Rogan cannot bomb at
that club right you know what I mean
that it's like they right everybody
coming is hoping they see him yes and
I've got jokes where it's like I want
the audience to be like oh [__] you know
I don't want them to be like yeah if I
say like you know let's talk about trans
people and everyone's like [__] yeah do
it then that's not my thing I want
people to be like [__] and then I show
them how I do it you know but that place
and this is not it's just because it's
new and people are excited about the
club but it doesn't seem it seems like a
little bit uh people will say come play
in our sandbox I want to play on the
beach uh I see what you're saying you
know yeah well I think that it's to a
good point that I think as you get when
people know you yeah a lot of times even
when I go on stage I'm like are they am
I good at this anymore or are people
just being you know who are uh fans of
mine or we have something in common are
they just you know I don't doubt myself
but you start did the the the the setup
changes it's not where you went on stage
for 14 years and they didn't know who
you were so you knew you got to win them
over yeah you knew there were so many
pieces of feedback that you were getting
that let you know you were genuin you
were doing well MH whereas now it's like
yeah am I still and then cuz they
they're there for you MH so it's like
how do you know how do you find an
audience then I mean I guess you just
pop on on shows where people don't know
you're going to be there maybe that's
probably the best way I mean TV was my
thing TV and like I never I wasn't like
I was I wasn't someone's opener and
that's how I kind of made my bones it
was like okay got on TV the roast kind
of showcase what I did to stand up
that's right and then it was like you
could go see me do that for an hour you
know it was it just worked out that I my
standup is very close to my roasting so
that's how I got everyone and I kind of
missed those days where I was surprised
to people because I don't have to earn
it anymore I just have to not let them
down if I don't let them down they're
going to come back you know I'll get one
tour where it's like Greatest Hits and
then after that then no one's coming to
see me again you know it's got to be
every time you come to see me it's going
to be all new and I've got it worked out
I'm not [__] around not I'm not like
messing around trying out stuff it's
like here's the act and I've kind of
taught people but a lot of times you
just go up there and hang out we've
we've all seen you know famous Comics go
and just do the hangout set and Chelle
does that a lot I feel like mhm you know
and that's it seems unpleasant to me I
don't want to waste everybody's
time yeah I I totally understand I don't
want to waste everybody's time but I'll
see like when I open for Chris Rock or I
would see Chris Rock at the store coming
and working on stuff and he would just
for like an hour just stand up on stage
in the main room going like what else
what else and I'm like I could never do
that right I could never never just be
sitting and the audience is wrapped
they're like we love this we'll sit here
and let watch you think all night I
could never I would start sweating if I
just like was like hm what else we like
I don't write on stage for that reason
I've got to have it down wow I write on
stage but I write like I'll be doing
something that I know is working and
it'll go a new little tributary will
start off of it and it's always that
whatever that new thing is if it does
well then it's locked in it works good
record or do you remember like it kills
so hard you're like okay I record all
the audio and I'll listen back cuz
you'll just get one new angle in like
the beginning of something you're like
oh this is this is
Monumental um did you see those aliens
those Mexican aliens the little tiny guy
yeah yeah and what' you think about it I
didn't give a flying [__] like space
outer space I don't care at all I'm glad
people are working on it I'm glad we're
going to Mars and all that [__] like I
go find out as much as you can about
that star but I don't give a [__] like
I've never seen a picture and been like
oh wow wow that's what a black hole
looks like like I don't it's got nothing
to do with me that like the aliens I was
like I don't believe it like yeah I know
you're talking to the government right
now but this would be a bigger deal and
if it was I still probably wouldn't care
yeah like this is this is legit little
alien guy it's like so what and it's
like a Mexican government which I'm not
saying is not as legitimate as any other
government but I think it has you know
there's definitely more of
like people you know like what's going
on here you know and they kind of did
like a un they like pulled it out of
like a they like mooved open a box it
was like a little bit of a cryp to like
I yeah I think the whole thing seemed a
little I don't I wonder if I care about
UFOs I I don't care they could attack
and I'd be like I don't like Wake Me Up
When I'm dead like I just don't it
doesn't interest me do you think our
government would let us know if they had
been here or not I don't I don't know if
they would I don't think they would
would do it to be like good but I also
don't think they would successfully
cover it up you know like the government
[__] up so much stuff that's why I
don't really believe in conspiracy
theories because like they would [__] it
up if they faked the moon landing they
would have [__] it up right someone
would have someone would have like
talked it would have been a thing and I
I'm going to see so many comments now
about like you're so dumb if you don't
believe like I don't care I don't want
to waste my time thinking about that
yeah it's like when crypto was a big
thing it's like I don't care I I like
money but I don't want to sit and think
about money right I like to have it I
don't want to look at the stock market I
don't want to look at my crypto things
and see what's going if I got to buy the
different coin now [__] that yeah I'm
not a crazy investor really a lot of
times because I just like to know what I
have I tell my business manager like am
I doing anything wrong am I doing
anything stupid let me know otherwise
like just pay my taxes yeah and like and
we're cool yeah dude I well think look
at that nft market that thing
disappeared I mean what the [__] was
that it sounded dumb from the jump I
would say it sounded dumb people be like
you you don't get it I'm like I think I
do and now it's all like everything's
been proven right like it's all it's all
gone yeah and I don't why the board AP
was wasn't good in the first place but
you're going to spend billions on this
thing it was very very dumb and I think
the person spending billions I think
it's just one guy telling his buddy hey
let's write an article that say you
spend a billion yeah and then we'll get
everybody else to buy [__] yeah it's
like the guy who said he spent a billion
never even spent a [__] billion I
spent I think they spent five grand
paying a website to make an article you
know computer money isn't real like I
don't I don't believe that you have like
a billion dollars in crypto that's the
same as having a billion dollars in real
money yeah I don't bu it do you think
you could have been like I've been
watching Banda Brothers have you been
watching it I I watched it when it first
came out God how good was it it was
great do you remember when Jimmy Fallon
shows up he's in it for like five
seconds it was clear it was like
everyone in Hollywood was getting into
this and it Fon just left SNL and it's
like they're about to go it's the end of
an episode like episode six or something
where they're like things are about to
get bad like we we've got no backup it's
just us we're each other's brothers and
all of a sudden they're like we don't
even have guns and all of a sudden he's
like hey guys and he they turn around
it's Jimmy Fallon in the uniform he he's
like Immaculate and he's like hey I
found some guns for you and they're like
really he's like yeah I'm just giving
them out and they like take the guns and
like thanks man he's like good luck guys
and that's the end of the episode it was
like clear that he like wanted to be a
part of it they were just like we we'll
work in a cameo somewhere let's give him
something good okay he gives the guys
guns at the end it was so so Hollywood
cheese wow does it stand out so much
from the episode yeah cuz no one else is
[__] famous you know you you have
like a couple guys who were like younger
actors but then it's like all a sudden
it's Jimmy [__] Fallon just post that
SNL you know it was hilarious to see him
in a World War II situation wow I didn't
even I might not be to the end of that
episode yet I'm watching this for the
second time now um dude Jimmy Fallon
when he first was doing touring he um
before he got SNL oh no before he got
The Tonight Show mhm he opened up for me
in Miami they had him they were putting
him on stage I guess to get his I mean I
say opened up like he they just put him
in the middle spot special guest spot he
do as much as he want if the crowd was
good he' do 20 if it was bad nobody knew
he was there I didn't even know till I
got there I go in the green room and
he's in there and uh and it was cool man
it was cool and then the last night I
think he just kind of he was doing fine
I think he just was uh getting kind of
over it you know yeah it was a Sunday
night show yeah doing guess sets like
everyone's excited but it's like you're
just doing I I totally I would get bored
doing guess sets too I just couldn't
believe it I was so scared of go in the
green room and then I didn't know what
to say when I was in there Green Room
gets small bro when you were just
learning about being a comedian and
you're in there with the headliner
because you don't know and the
headliners are [__] we're crazy we're
crazy we very specific and particular
how we're used to things yeah and some
people like that's their whole that's
the only time they have any power they
don't have power out on stage but like
in the green can be like get the [__]
get out of here with that cheeseburger
you're like relax man but like now I
know enough like have you ever just had
some some random person walk in your
green room yeah like put their jacket
down you're like and they walk out
you're like what and they're like no
they shouldn't have done that like oh I
didn't know to tell someone like I once
yelled at the comedy store's lawyer who
was like eating dinner in the in the
green room I was like are you comic and
he's like no get the [__] out of here
and then someone comes back and like
that's the lawyer like I like well he's
still he shouldn't be back here he sure
the [__] shouldn't have been back there
dude thankfully he's in heaven now that
guy passed away no he did but uh yeah
but um but hey that's what he gets for
[__] eating in the Green Room should
have come in my Green Room bro when
you're not a comedian dude bro when you
cross the Dark Art the [__] last son
of Transylvania and you go into his
green room and eat you're in for trouble
you're going to die you got about a year
to live do you think you could have
handled like the draft or something like
that sometimes I feel like we need
another War do you think that's a crazy
thought yes why cuz what the [__] did we
get out of most of them you know you can
look at World War II and be like okay
like that was we fighting for something
but now Technology's gotten so crazy
with uh with everything that I don't
know if anyone would do the draft I
don't would have the uh the you know the
nationality to just be like blindly
follow the government they don't want to
do that if it was a real if we got
attacked I bet everyone signs up the
next day but if it's just like hey uh we
noce something's going on in North Korea
again like get the we're not doing that
get the [__] out of here bro I used to
think I would have just gone into the
draft like my dad was in the military I
have certainly have respect for it do I
think I'd be a good soldier absolutely
[__] not so like you would be the
worst yeah like I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna drag the rest of the troops down
let's head to Canada and do my part over
there yeah that's what I I I think what
I want is I want something to unify
people I want something that makes us
feel I miss the days I think when we all
felt like we were part of a country or
it seemed to me like we felt like we
were like I don't know how how that all
that just I don't know if I felt like I
was part of the go if I was
like if I love the government really if
I just love the idea of our country you
know you know what I'm saying like when
you're a kid like yeah I mean no if you
love the government you're [__] dumb
like if you like I get Ling the country
if you're like this government the
[__] IRS is killer man I love him so
much if you love politicians like people
were like oh like [__] the Joe Biden
it's like okay I'm I'm down [__] the
president always if you're like [__]
this guy the last guy was amazing like
get the [__] out of here every
politician [__] sucks I would never
do that with my life there are some I
like more than others but like
politicians in general get the [__] out
of here like why am I supposed to like
this one no they're all they're all
politicians it's insane yeah I think
well if you ever I've always thought if
you ever my mother always let us know if
you ever think the government is going
to do something for your life then
that's not how it's going to work
probably um I'll never get over the
government saying every year pay your
taxes figure it out pay your taxes and
you you try to do whatever math you have
you send it to and they go you got it
wrong then [__] tell me what it is
send me a bill don't make me do these
gymnastics and then tell me I'm wrong
like why are you making me do this and
that's what I think about the government
so passive aggressive that's very
passive aggressive of them and also you
know there used to be a box you check it
you get for being blind right you get
1,600 bucks right but you have to check
the [__] box dude like how do they
even
like I just don't understand what there
should be a box that you don't check if
you're blind yeah if you can see check
this box if not you're going down and
they don't even tell you what it's for
it just says hey if you can see check
this box that would have been the best
way to know if people are blind you know
what's always obsessed to me about blind
people and I us to try to turn this into
a joke and can never do it is you know
like you know what Braille is right the
little dots they read it's like think
about how long it takes a blind person
like let's say you lost your vision
today how long do you think it would
take you to learn Braille like one Dot's
a two is B this is C like I bet probably
two months two months 60 days 62 days
tops um you know what maybe to be for uh
fluent I would say maybe six months six
months okay how long then once you know
how to read Braille does it take you to
find
Braille oh yeah if you're blind you can
read the [__] out of it how do you find
it are you just always looking around
like any bump you're just like ah bank I
can read again like you go to the bank
and it's like on the ATM but like how do
you find the ATM like I don't know I
don't know how they ever do it they
should have made Braille way bigger for
blind people yeah they should have made
it a huge they should have made it like
speed bumps in a parking lot when you're
pulling in hear yeah run your finger
over and it's like your your tires go
over it and you feel like oh it
communicates to your car or something
that communicates to you or you do it
makes a sound when you go over but yeah
I mean the blind they've been [__]
shun by Society for so long I feel like
or just you know nobody cared that much
it's like yeah we'll give you this
little series of do people don't trust
blind people yeah oh no you don't trust
deaf people you don't trust blind people
you're like I you can see a little bit
you can see something yeah you can you
can hear loud noises you're just playing
this up oh yeah I remember they had a
dude in our town who uh he was deaf
right and he was doing this and um
people beat him up for doing bad magic
you know they thought he was doing like
the evil eye kind of [__] yeah [__] like
this and they thought he you know never
pulled out a quarter or anything and
people [__] lit into him you know
that's why you got to carry a quarter oh
no matter how deaf you are M get that
kid a
quarter what's an ailment do you think
you could
handle I mean I think you can handle
whatever like right now I'm dealing with
like back issues where like my back
sucks and I'm like seeing a chiropractor
doing exercises like all this stuff and
I'm like I'm dealing with it like
sometimes it's better than others but
I'm dealing with it that anything it's
like when you get sick you get the flu
and you're like you feel like you've had
the flu for your entire life and it's
never going away and then one day you're
like ah the cff's gone like it's over
that I think I could handle whatever
there's not I wouldn't want these things
but if I lost a limb you know I think I
could I could handle it I've always
wanted to lose an eye I would love to
wear an eye patch I would love to have
just one eye like a black leather eye
patch A cool one and that's my thing
people say glass eyes is the way to go I
don't I disagree eye patch
if it's like the scar going down in the
eye patch forget oh yeah coming out the
bottom of it you would be able to do
that though I think there's a thing
about being tall and handsome you get a
you get
there's there's so much stuff you get to
do that you don't realize that other
people don't get to do like a little guy
with an eye patch is a [__] that guy
terrible it's well it's just nobody's
going to give a [__] it's too much it's
yeah it's too pick one yeah be little do
an iPad but don't [__] come in here
mhm you
know
yeah yeah I think I always was
fascinated I remember when I was a kid I
met a kid that had a stutter right this
kid named Douglas and I'd never heard it
before and I was so jealous I was like
he sounds so unique like I want to be
and I remember I would impersonate him a
lot right like I was in I mean I loved
it and my teacher got mad at me and I
was like no you don't want to like I
think it's I think it's cool awesome
like he sounds unique
as a kid I made fun of someone with a
stutter and the kid's mom was like don't
do that if you if you make draw
attention to it'll have it forever but
if you just don't mention it he'll stop
and I was like oh why is this my job wow
like you guys deal with that at home in
the real world we're talking about it
we're talking about that stutter dude I
can't believe I tried to put that on you
that's crazy it's like I'm eight what a
responsibility but that's what you get
when you're tall dude when you're tall
people I feel like you get [__] put
everything gets put on you I feel like
when you're tall how tall are you I'm
just regular heighted I'm 6 foot okay
and I I was kind of tall for a little
while but everybody just I didn't it
didn't play out and um and then but I
the tall kid always [__] remember
when you got tall remember just like one
four weeks you're like and your neck was
long and your [__] chin was like my
neck always hurt like there were like
three years where I was always doing
this like my neck and it was like I'm
growing I didn't know at the time my
neck just like was always sore and I
shot up like I was the tallest kid in my
class immediately and then I just
stopped so and I thought I was like I
thought I was big and I was just tall I
wasn't big at all I was like a bean
Poole but people wanted to fight you yes
I was like oh the tall guy I want to
fight him I was I don't him this 40 year
old and you're like I'm 11 I'm seven I'm
11 yeah
nine
um what else do you think about like
your career do you feel like did you
feel like success gave you a lot of the
things you thought it would or or were
you surprised by any of that I was
surprised at how little I was able to
enjoy it like I didn't want to be famous
I wanted to be known I wanted to be able
to like comedians would know who I was
you know you if you're a comic and you
don't know who I am you're not a comic
like right you wanted to be valid yes
that I could walk into a club and they
like oh Anthony you're here uh that's
pretty powerful too isn't it when you
think about like that being able to
happen oh yeah walking into like a green
room like I just I go to see Doug Stan
help and I'm like I want to go backstage
maybe they'll let me back and I walk
back and they're like oh hey oh yeah
come on back in you're like oh that's
cool it almost feels false doesn't it or
does it ever feel like that to you not
that you don't deserve it to me there's
no doubt but even when people welcome me
like I would go to the the uh comedy
seller sometimes like the last time was
there like do you want to get up and I
was like not me MH like I don't just get
up you know like I you know if Colin
Quinn comes in you know or if somebody
like a new you know like sure but there
like I always say when it comes to that
like you want to drop in I'm like if you
didn't buy ticket to see me you don't
want to see me I'm not a good dropping
because it's like you're here to see
whatever else and then it's like my dead
baby [__] for 15 minutes and they're
just like what the [__] and I'm like
yeah you're right like I should I'm
ruining your good time so it's like I
want people to know that I'm coming I'm
not I'm not a good surprise um but I
really hated 2013 was when like the J
offensive was on the air I was like
right after the roasts and everything I
did my first special where I was for
that year I was famous then the show got
cancelled like I had couple years off TV
and it was like it went away almost
immediately where it was just like the
temperature got dialed down but I didn't
like people looking at you and being
like I know you from something I don't
know what it is but like I know you that
I hated if it's like I love your comedy
thank you so much great I love that but
just I've seen you on something I hated
I really hated being famous you know
yeah I think it's uh it feels exhausting
it feels like a whole another life you
have to live mhm yes it's like you're
not just doing the one show you're doing
shows all the time and you don't know
when it's happening like you're walking
through the airport and then you like
get home when you see someone's been
folling you around taking pictures and
posting them all and they're like this
is just weird and it gets in your head I
get people who wear sunglasses all the
time I get the I get the hat and like
the disguise and just like I don't want
to be out in public like I stopped going
to bars like it was just being around
any drunk people was worst in the world
that's one thing I love about not
drinking is just not having to deal with
that type of energy or like because it's
already weird enough if somebody knows
you but then I think if they're wasted
it makes you just kind of scared this
just too risky oh yeah and then they
come they want to come back it's like
hey I just want to say I'm a huge fan
like thank you and they like can I get a
picture five minutes later like I just
wanted to tell you this one joke and
you're like this is my home yeah my
sister's here yeah dude my [__] she
loves you she wants to FaceTime you yeah
and I get it they're fans like it's cool
but like you know they pay buy tickets
but when they're drunk it is really
tough to deal with yeah one guy put me
on the phone with his sister and she's
fck fighting with her husband like
having a [__] fist fight with her
husband right in some house somewhere
and I'm
like and the guy's like she loves you
he's so drunk he doesn't realize her
having like a domestic dispute or
something he's like she loves you and
I'm just like she's you know she's down
two rounds to zero against against
Stanley right here you know I'll never
do the video I'll never take the phone
like if they went like hey can I get a
picture of course sign this like I got
into the airport today and these like
three guys with like stack of [__] I'm
just like it's easier just to do this
and get out of here but I'm like this is
all going on eBay this is dumb as [__]
but it's easier just to do it but I feel
like would you do a video for my friend
who couldn't make it no yeah I'm not I'm
not doing that were you bum when the
roast kind of went away did that bum you
out no I was I was uh I was happy to do
three and then done perch for you yeah
and it was I mean it was all I wanted to
do I was like building my act towards
getting on that the Trump roast was like
my big break my life was night and day
after that then the sheen roast came
like a couple months later it wasn't
that long and that was even bigger and
that I felt insane pressure because I
was like well that was my big break and
I those were jokes that I've been
working on forever now I've got four
months this is my sophomore album that
could tank and I didn't want it to seem
like oh I got lucky so that roast was so
stressful and then it was like a year
until the Rosanne was my last one and
that was a let down it wasn't have the
same uh like hype to it that Trump and
Sheen had like the next I remember I
showed the next weekend and like the T
sales were just normal like it wasn't
like I didn't get the bump that I got
after Sheen and Trump that I was like
you know I don't really want to do this
anymore it's like it's just not fun
telling the same kinds of jokes and I
didn't approach it like Jeff Ross who
was just like Jeff Ross could do it
forever right to anyone no one's getting
mad he's just perfect at it my thing was
like too like Darth Vader like I was
coming to kill everyone there and it
just I didn't want to do it again that
people ask me every now and again I'm
like it would take it would take a lot
it would it would have to be money
because I just feel like I've done it
and I feel like I did it perfectly right
did to come back it just I feel the
pressure you know I feel the pressure to
perform like the audience might be there
to see me and they've loved my last four
hours but this fifth hour better measure
up or I feel terrible so hype yeah and I
guess once you do something and doing it
well then that's enough knowing when to
not do something anymore is important do
you think Comedy Central how they mess
up I mean they were they were the only
comedy network via Comm [__] it up for
everybody at at a time when Disney was
buying Marvel at a time where Disney was
buying you know like Warner Brothers all
this [__] Viacom was just like enriching
themselves they weren't investing and
then when streaming came along it just
wiped them all out but like MTV's gone
and Comedy Central is still technically
around but it's like five people now and
they're not getting to stand up that
maybe things come back a little bit but
it was just they and I've talked to many
many people over there over the years
about what happened but it is crazy
though like you were the Comedy Network
work mhm you had comedy yeah remember it
took them forever to get into like
social they just didn't they were like
so behind somehow so behind yeah just
didn't didn't really care that much
didn't have to but they're figuring out
now and they made some bad they just
didn't have they didn't have that good a
p like they only had a few shows that
really crushed it for them I think you
know and they wouldn't pay to get three
seasons was almost impossible even two
was like a stretch I mean look it's like
SNL you see the people who like didn't
get S who like auditioned for SNL and
didn't get her fired after a year you
know and their careers how amazing it's
been like a Sarah Silverman or something
um that uh Comedy Central is the same
way it's like all these huge stars that
like people think Comedy Central let
them go it's like they couldn't afford
them yeah what John Oliver's what um not
John John Oliver is making HBO versus
what he made on Comedy Central is insane
uh Steven coar you know had to leave at
Comedy Central they just didn't have the
money there yeah Schumer owed the uh Amy
Schumer owed them another season I think
of her show I don't know if she ended up
doing it or not but I remember she had
had the what is this show called inside
am inside am Schumer I think they
contractually had one more season that
she was supposed to do because then she
just blew up so much that she just
didn't and maybe they just did like a
buy out of it or something I just
remember she did it she did one for per
plus oh she did oh maybe that was it
then yeah maybe that was it
um I was I have friends who would like
sign a deal get paid and then like hope
the network forgets about it oh yeah was
like quby remember quibby oh yeah God I
wish I had taken a deal from them this
free money deals yeah they're like
here's 100 grand three weeks later they
were totally out of business like what's
the best job you've ever had in terms of
that like for me it was uh judging roast
battle where it was just like every I go
I show up oh yeah like you're you're
they're they're paying you amazing and
you don't have to prepare anything you
just sit there and then they do their
bit and then you think of a joke and you
say it and then it's everything was
great and if you mess up they edit it
out like it's so cool zero pressure paid
paid uh a ton and uh and just so much
fun I love that that was yeah one of the
best jobs I ever had actually was a
Comedy Central job it was called um
reality btes back I watched I watched
Reality Bites back uh Amy had it all on
like DVD and we watched it so good the
show was so [__] funny I can't
believe it didn't like no one watched it
but it was it was great I can't believe
they didn't start to reair things that
they had that were great but I guess
they don't have is that a fiscal maybe
they have to rerent it from themselves I
don't know how that work I think just no
one watched it no one was watching it if
they would rerun it they were just like
let's let's get rid of this but it had
like Schumer on it uh a uh Tiffany
hadish Berke kryer like if they put it
out now it seemed like it would do fine
yeah you would think you know it's it's
weird how comedy doesn't live that long
even if it is all like the stars of
yesterday people just they'd rather
watch you now but it's like I can watch
like uh Summer Heights High right have
you ever seen that oh yeah and uh and it
don't it's still get it's still like so
rid it still gets me but it's like I
mean one of the best shows Comedy
Central ever made was um Strangers With
Candy and they never reran that like
ever you have to like you had to find it
on I used to buy it on eBay I'd buy like
a season on eBay for someone who burned
like the DVDs that [__] was amazing my
favorite roast of all time was the roast
of Chevy Chase the one that was like a
fiasco but it's like Todd Berry Andy
Kindler like Mark Mar to the roers and
it's so [__] awesome but it tanked
and they like Comedy Central was just
like we threw it away like you if you
can find it on YouTube go for it but we
don't have a copy of it we'll never
rerun it and we just got rid of it
that's crazy it seems like if you put
the roast of Chevy Chase on a network TV
right now people would tune in like what
do you think about like our Netflix
specials like things we've done there's
no physical media anymore like that can
all go away and you're left with like
nothing nothing and that's wild to me
that a corporation who knows what you
get canceled for but they can just be
like all your work is gone it's gone as
if it never existed and there's nothing
you can do nothing oh it's very scary I
think you know I went to the last
Blockbuster not long ago where's that
it's in Bend Oregon yes and I have an
ex-girlfriend that lives up there and
it's a beautiful town and uh and I went
in there and you know what's fascinating
the most fascinating was how you used to
see you saw so many titles you're over
here it's like in Brugge and here's like
you know uh Daddy Daycare or whatever
you know here's like you know uh llama
town or whatever and it's like oh [__] I
you don't know what to choose but you
see so I mean you were here and then you
were in and you'd walk through you be
like I oh I forgot about this movie this
is great I've never seen this but it was
so different than when you go to a
platform on your television and you see
titles it was another it felt like you
actually here's what it felt like I'm
realizing it felt like you actually had
a choice in what you were choosing mhm
in the Blockbuster right then as opposed
to on the TV where it feels like this is
what you we're serving today even though
that's not it you can go look for stuff
but it's just not it what it didn't
register the same no and it's it's even
annoying where Netflix I don't know if
they still do this but like if they know
your something's right up your alley
like they have all your algorithm
whatever there was a movie that came out
like a couple years ago right before my
like last special came out and now I was
talking to Netflix at the time and have
you ever seen the Night Comes for us did
you ever see the raid or the raid too
it's kind like a martial like a super
violent martial arts movie where people
are just fighting with like machetes and
[__] and it's awesome and I see it I'm
like this is the best [__] thing I've
ever seen why would Netflix tell me hey
good news we got this new movie for you
and so they told me basically if they
know you're going to see it if they know
like this is right up your alley they
won't put it on your screen because they
know you'll go look for it and they want
you to find other things on your way to
it that's like you can't they know what
you want but they're still going to make
you look for it and that makes me
[__]
crazy yeah it feels like privatized
communism in a way does that make any
sense am I thinking of things wrong I
mean it's a funny way to say it like I
get what you mean it feels
like yeah it just cuz stuff like that
it's like it's fine but in the end
you're just I'm going to watch what you
want me to watch and I won't be a soul
in you know I'll just
be like I'll be a firefly but
you'll own them
gasoline or the match you know it's like
I'll just
never I don't know stuff like that makes
me feel kind of defeated sometimes all
makes me feel old I'm just like I'm not
really in maybe it's just an older
thought of it huh I don't know I could
be because we're in the industry so we
kind of understand and the there's the
way Netflix is secretive pisses me off
then again list I I love Netflix I'm
glad I have specials on there uh but
it's annoying that they're just like
they won't tell you don't know how good
something did it can tell they can say
trending not trending you have no
[__] clue like it's doing great like
I remember my last special there like in
the first week this many people watched
it yeah and I was like that's great give
me something to compare it to I don't
that that number means nothing to me
unless you say Ali Wong got this in two
weeks you know what I mean like I don't
understand what any of the any of the
stuff they say and they could tell you
hey most of your people watch you in
Chicago most people do that like that
way you know where to tour and they
won't tell you right they don't give you
anything and and they'll be like we know
I'm like well
no one's ever quit and just been like
let me tell you what what happened like
I would love to go like Undercover Boss
to Netflix and just look up my [__] and
then peace out well YouTube is
interesting too because it's like you
can't even talk to someone in the system
like they took down an episode that we
had and we couldn't even you communicate
kind of with like this medium but
there's no way to email you don't even
know who's in the like who the levels
the boss you don't even know who's
making the choice it's like really yes
it's this ambient sort
of you don't know cuz like my I've got a
social media team you know they're
they're great but they're like we know a
guy we have a guy at Instagram we'll get
you verified like right now we have a
guy at Tik Tok we talk to when all my
[__] gets taken down all the time and
like No it should be okay because of
this but they have someone to deal with
that I I can't believe YouTube doesn't
have that with all the I mean there's so
much money coming through YouTube I know
that I can't believe Mr Beast doesn't
have a guy's number I don't I bet now
maybe at that level you do you know but
yeah maybe at our level we don't we have
a contact there but it's not there's
never like you just get the verdict from
the contact and that's the verdict it's
very like ancient Rome it feels like you
know and what was the reason they took
it down oh Roseanne had a joke she said
I remember this yeah um that the
Holocaust never happened right and it
she was being satirical right and you
know she's also get you know I
think they didn't think she was or they
didn't want to hear it you know and so
they said that it gets taken down and um
and nobody said anything at first and
then there's like some of these like
biters online they put the clip out and
they're like what about you know and
that's when it built up stuff but the
only way we can communicate kind of is
through our we have a contact there that
works with YouTube but they never
there's never able to have a discussion
that's the strange part sometimes and
that's where I think you start to
feel you know like you aren't being
heard or you don't have somebody to
communicate with I I mean I stopped
doing that with comedy where I used to
be like here's why this joke is okay you
know I mean like I know it's a
technically it's about domestic violence
but if you look at the wording no one's
getting hit in this joke this joke is
like referencing it but it's pretention
and it's always a losing battle I'd be
arguing with sensors or something and
and now I just if you I can't do it I
can't do it [__] it I'm not going to
change it but I'll just get rid of it so
I'm not going to sit here and have the
argument of why this is okay and now I
just hope that people understand like
I've got you know a lot of topics that I
talk about that would get people in
trouble but I've I've gotten away with
it I don't know if it's reputation or
people just know now that no he did it
in the the right way he got away with it
but like it goes back to what you're
saying there's a way to get away like
what did you say in the beginning you
said art is getting away with it
yeah yeah I think there was something
about getting yeah I wanted to for me it
was always I wanted to say what I wanted
to say let me suffer the consequences
mhm you know but I want to say this was
that the most trouble you've ever gotten
was the Roseanne thing have you ever had
like a on social media yeah and then all
the like different sit said stuff about
it and I never replied to any of it and
within 48 Hours yeah completely gone I
remember asking Rogan about that once it
was like remember when Joe Rogan was
like I think I'd vote for Bernie Sanders
and the [__] internet went crazy for
like a week because it's like a guy said
he was going to vote for I was like
how'd you handle that he goes I turned
my phone off and hung out with my kids
for a couple coup days and then I turn
it on and everything's fine I'm like
it's such a healthy way to do it it's
like this is happening it's not real
just turn it off and and uh come back
yeah it's not really real that's what it
seemed like yeah real when you're
younger you're like oh I [__] up this
is over now cuz I had some of those
earlier on and now you're like it's fine
oh yeah I remember get taking pills
after something bad happened one time I
thought I was going to die I thought my
life was over mhm thought about moving
back you know I thought everything was
done um I still that still makes me mad
what happened in Bernie remember they
just his own party kind of railroaded
him you know with ber or with Bernie
Sanders it was like just the fact that
he would have a chance to run against I
don't remember who I don't if it was
Obama second term and he want is going
to try and run against him that must
have been it I don't know if he ran ran
against Obama second term but I know he
ran against Hillary he ran the first
time right he was trying to run against
Hillary and he didn't get the nomin like
a lot of people thought oh he'll get the
a chance to go against Hillary to see
who gets it and his party just kind of
said no yeah it was like what I don't
get the the politics of it of like hey
let's all just back this person why
don't you just vote for what you want
and then see how it plays out yeah not
like let's talk beforehand it's I wish
that you know in Congress they would one
bill at a time like you can't just be
like here's a bill to try to get student
aid and also homeless people it's like
do one at a time and do what makes sense
it's all it's all totally [__] and
maybe it has to be that way I don't know
that's the thing I don't know sometimes
too it's like I don't know if that's
just how the business you know it's like
it's too much for me to know sometimes
like do you ever SE I watched a
documentary like what are the happiest
countries in the world oh yeah with uh
rain Wilson was in it no I don't know if
I I didn't watch that much of it to see
who but they had said the happiest
country was like I want to say Denmark
it was like somewhere in Scandinavia
where they all live in like com like
like communal like buildings and they
eat their meals together and everyone's
happy and the least happy is Japan
because they're just like they work
their [__] asses off and then the
only break they get is when they throw
themselves in front of a bullet train or
some [__] but it's [__] it seems is
brutal just the culture of it that maybe
that's what you know American government
has to be I don't know what government
is killing it out there government like
our system is so dope like it's all it's
great we kill it that's the thing it's
like and you start to wonder is this
just house capitalism tails off like is
this how America kind of starts to tail
off where everything where big
corporations seem like they own
everything and own all of our attention
span and then at some point somebody you
know too many cities get like there's
too much crime and the scale tips and
Society starts to [__] the fabric
comes apart I think I mean being you
know almost 45 years old now I feel like
it's just a pend pendulum it's just it's
like okay we're going to get Obama and
then it's just G to get real racist and
then we're going to get like another and
then it's gonna like you're just going
to get progressive and then swing back
yeah like Trump is a direct response to
Obama you know that that I think is just
going to keep going back and forth like
that yeah I think that's one thing I
mean we had Robert Kennedy was on here
and he's trying to he's a he's a democr
and he's um trying to I think he's going
to run as an independent now and you
almost cuz you I always heard that the
independent if they get a certain number
of votes and they get a share of the
pool the money pool did you ever hear
that no like there's like an advertise
like there's a amount of money they can
budget that is divided up between the
two parties but if a third one gets 5% I
think then they get part of the pool as
well like before the runoff like if
there's a I don't know um sounding like
a just a guy in a [__] bar but if um
I would love to see there be a third
opport like I would just love for there
to see something change up the status
quo yeah you know yeah have an extra
Choice like they you know tell us what
your things are and we'll figure out
which one it is but it's I don't know I
hate it feel like they've got us so
cornered though when there's only you
know it just starts to feel like
everything there's so many strings going
on in the distance of everything you
know yeah it's like it's not really a
choice right it's like we need somebody
to come through with the scissors man
you always come through with the
scissors man with your comedy dude I
just want to thank you for being so
entertaining man and um thanks for just
sitting and chatting with me man yeah
I'm happy this worked out we were in
town at the same time it was it's fun to
finally be on the podcast yeah man and
to get to chat even and I've never
really talked that much before this is
the longest we've ever talked for sure
it is cool man thanks Anthony thanks for
having
me now just floating on thee and
iing like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of mind I found I can
feel it
[Music]
myones